[Music]
thank you
welcome back to another episode of
what's up Prof
hi Martin hello Walter
I'm glad you have a little bit of a
voice now a little bit it's not quite
there yet yeah so please bear with my
voice and we'll see how it goes we'll
get the Lord we'll trust the Lord to
raise you up it's coming it's coming
right it's coming right it's been a bit
of a slog but it's coming right let's
open the with the word of Prayer
heavenly father thank you so much for
helping us to carry on thank you for
giving us the opportunity to do these
discussions and thank you for giving us
the strength please be with us now as we
present this and let your name be
glorified in Jesus name amen Martin we
spoke about many things in the last one
and a little discussion on the Apocrypha
created a bit of a hornet's nest I
didn't expect that quite so seriously
but well tell us what happened
well a lot of some comments that we
received stated that we did not
distinguish between the Old Testament
Apocrypha and the New Testament
Apocrypha you see the Old Testament
Apocrypha also included in the original
King James
but the uh the Protestants came to their
senses and removed them threat and I
don't think it was in any case when it
wasn't the King James even then seen as
in inspired scripture except in the
Catholic Church the Roman Catholic
Church States canonically
that they must be seen canonically and
if you don't see it that way you're in
anathma that that's a little bit of a
problem for people that's continuously
trying to uplift the Apocrypha
Martin if the Beast of Revelation is
determined to put something in
that backs some of its doctrines but is
contrary to the rest of scripture they
used to be very suspicious why go down
that road why do you go down that road
and if I remember correctly in that
episode I also mentioned that if you
want to know more of what happened for
instance in the Old Testament times with
Israel you can read Patriarchs and
Prophets so that will already have given
you a clue that we did include the Old
Testament Apocrypha in this whole
discussion but for clarity's sake I
thought okay maybe let's just look at
some of these books of the Old Testament
Apocrypha and see what it states and
then we can see if it's in harmony with
scripture well let me put it quite
plainly the New Testament Apocrypha are
a load of rubbish
and uh if somebody didn't get it there
are a load of rubbish because they
contain absolute
irrational
illogical
unscientific and biblical unbiblical
nonsense
but some of them are written so so
nicely like The Book of Enoch for
example
let it gets away with it with
contradicting scripture
and just being enough in line and giving
information that sounds so interesting
but really is irrelevant to your
salvation true true and then I read that
you know some people are upset because
of the cycle of the week
but I read in Ellen G white
that God marvelously preserved the cycle
of the week from the beginning yet she
saw that and if she saw that and people
say but he didn't do it
well then God is either incapable
or she's a false prophet one of the two
one of the two I also had the discussion
because
if God changed if the cycle was changed
God rectified it like we've mentioned
many times before with a manner
many many instances we've dealt with it
but let's go to these things and see
what this is about before we get to our
topic
Martin my voice is not quite there yet
so I'm going to appoint you as the
reader I'll try my best let's see what's
going on here
okay so this is in the Book of Tobit
the traveling companion of okay so this
is a description of what's going on in
the in this book and let's see what we
can glean from this
the traveling companion of Tobias on his
journey was the angel Raphael although
his identity was unknown to either Tobit
autobias on the way to Media when he was
bathing Tobias was attacked by a large
fish the fish was killed Rafael then
told Tobias to remove the heart and lung
from the fish because it would make
useful medicine
at the same time Tobit was asking the
law to take his life there was a woman
in media named Sarah who was also
requesting to die she had lost seven
husbands each on the night of their
honeymoon
a demon named asmodius had entered into
their bed chamber and killed each one of
these men thus Sarah wished to die then
Tobias arrived in media he was urged by
Raphael to marry Sarah instead of
becoming the eighth victim of the demon
Tobias used the liver and Heart Of The
Dead Fish to drive the demon from the
bed chamber when Tobias and Sarah
returned to Nineveh he used part of the
fish to rub unto the eyes of his blind
father at that moment Tobit was cured
from his blindness Raphael then revealed
his eye true identity to Tobit he was an
angel sent by God to answer tobit's
prayer there are a number of obvious
historical and geographical errors in
this book that make it historically
impossible as noted legendary elements
are also found in this story so that's
the commentary of the writeria Martin if
this book is inspired
then I have lost all respect for
inspiration
this book has got magic in it as well
seems to me this
fish mooty that you have to do then the
shangomas in Africa seems to be doing
quite well yes so we don't need Jesus
Jesus is the one who drives our demons
he's the only one who can
even Gabriel required the assistance of
Mikhail
so Martin if people want to be Gold
Blood on hot addicts of fish they're
welcome to it they can go and catch as
many fish as they like cut out the
gallbladders and the hearts and go like
priests and put them in a little bottle
with perhaps a little bit of smoke and
drive out all the demons if they really
think
that that stupidity will work they're
quite welcome
as far as I'm concerned this book has
nothing to do with scripture and it has
no place in Scripture and if the Roman
Catholics like it because they like
Hocus Pocus then that's their problem
correct so people can judge from
themselves read it so let's see another
book
the book of Judith
so Judith is the account of a Jewish
woman who saves her people by killing an
enemy leader there does not seem to be a
historical basis for this story the book
contains a number of historical and
chronological errors in fact Judith
begins with a couple of obvious
historical errors it says it was the
12th year of Reign of Nebuchadnezzar who
ruled over the Assyrians in the great
city of Nineveh in those days arafaksat
ruled over the meat in egg bhaktana
that's in Judith one verse 1.
Nebuchadnezzar was the ruler of the
Babylonians not the Assyrians
furthermore he ruled in Babylon not
Nineveh these are grave historical eras
that show the legendary character of
this book in fact The New American Bible
a Roman Catholic translation makes the
following admission concerning the book
of Judith any attempt to read this book
directly against the backdrop of Jewish
history in relation to the empires of
the world is bound to fail prologue to
Judith what this simply means is that
the entire account of the book of Judith
is fictional there is a more serious
problem according to the book of Judith
God assists Judith in telling a number
of Lies Judith lies to their syrians by
saying that she is hiding from her
people once she has gained their trust
she is able to kill their Leader by her
deceit
well I think leave it at that and more
do you want to say Martin I don't want
to say anything I think people must
judge from themselves what do you want
to take the book of Judith rather than
the book of Kings as your reference you
want to replace the Book of Esther with
Judith
I think people can judge for themselves
on this one let's go to another book
okay this book is Belle and the dragon
bell or Bell and the snake it consists
of two stories these two accounts
ridicule idolatry and show how the gods
of Babylon are without power okay in the
Second Story Daniel asked permission of
the king to kill the dragon they were
worshiping he said but give me
permission O King and I will kill the
dragon without sword or Club the king
said I give you permission then Daniel
took pitch fat and hair and boiled them
together and made cakes which he fed to
the dragon the dragon ate them and burst
open then Daniel said see what you have
been worshiping
the Babylonians then became upset
because Daniel had destroyed two of
their Idols they convinced the king to
throw Daniel into a Den of Lions the
story concludes by showing that God
protected Daniel from the lines during
the six days that he was in the den on
the seventh day the king arrived at the
Lion's Den to find Daniel safe Belle and
the dragon is added to the Book of
Daniel as Daniel chapter 14 in Roman
Catholic translations and as a separate
work in Protestant translations
dribble so you actually got two versions
of the story of Daniel and the lion
Daniel and the lions and of in the
biblical one Daniel is thrown into the
lion's den why because He follows true
worship
here there's a lot of Hocus Pocus and
nonsense
well if you want to believe that
you're quite welcome but this isn't
a gel with the rest of the Bible no so
why do you want these books to be
canonical because they support Hocus
Pocus I don't know but it's up to you
the reader and to live listener himself
too do you really think that the Dragon
would burst open from a cake of pitch
fat and hair
sounds like a tasty morsel why would he
eat it in the first place
oh no let's have a look at another book
the book of second Maccabees now before
you go to Maccabees Martin these are
historical books right and I've always
maintained if you want to read them as
an addendum then we're fine
but uh it's like adding the Encyclopedia
Britannica and saying read this as an
addendum to the Bible yeah they can put
Josephus also in there correct and say
that their history is more accurate than
that recorded in the Bible
if you believe that the Bible is an
inspired book
then the other books must be judged by
what is written in the Bible and not the
Bible judged by what is written in other
books so if you want an additional
historical source
then use one that is inspired
so if you want to study the Old
Testament we've always quite plainly
said read Patriarchs and Prophets and
Prophets and kings and then you have one
that is in Harmony
and expandery if you like on what is
happening in the Bible and even it
explains very well
um on Enoch well interesting also is a
lot of people say okay but Jude refers
to Enoch and there's a lot of verses
that refers to you know my question once
again is the Book of Enoch is not in
harmony with a Bible so then that the
reference cannot beat to that book
well Martin let's just read that passage
in the Bible let's do that
in the book of Jude
in verse 14.
it says and Enoch also the servant from
Adam let's just stop right there
what Enoch is he referring to
The Godly one The Godly that walked with
God correct the seventh from Adam
because the other Inno was the son of
Cain he came before this Adam
now we have clearly shown in many
lectures
and you can derive it from morals and
Dogma by Albert Pike
at Freemason who derives its wisdom from
Enoch's son of Cain
because the chronology that he uses
cannot refer to the good inner it can
only refer to the evil Enoch son of Cain
now that religion of the evil Enoch came
through and went all the way through via
probably a ham
to namrad and spread on
so the religion of Freemasonry which is
luciferian
traces its line from Enoch
so when you have the deities
that you have they refer to Cain and to
Enoch
so Marduk will be you know for example
now
this one is referring to Enoch as the
seventh from Adam
and this one was taken to heaven without
seeing death
now surely Enoch must have prophesied
about the coming of the Lord definitely
and Enoch also the seventh from Adam
prophesied of these saying behold the
Lord cometh with ten thousand of his
Saints to execute judgment upon all
and to convince all that are ungodly
among them of all the ungodly Deeds
which they have ungodly committed and of
all the hard speeches which ungodly
Sinners have spoken against him
Martin is is there anything in there
that contradicts scripture No it's
hundred percent in in line with and
obviously the Enoch that walked with God
would say everything in harmony with
scripture why would you want to go into
a deep theological discussion about the
book of enochna and Peter
is the one who came in support of of
Jude
because even then he must have received
some Flack and he repeated many of the
things without mentioning the book of
enochero at all
and that's the thing and just once more
The Book of Enoch contradicts the Bible
so it cannot be the book by the true
Enoch
let's just leave it at that
all right so here we have a historic
book
but let's see what additional little
tidbits there can appear in an historic
book exactly right let's read this so
let's see and second Maccabees it's not
as historically accurate as First
Maccabees it has several chronological
errors and also contains a number of
contradictions as well as some fanciful
and legendary material the final section
chapter 10 relates the successful
military campaign of Judas Maccabees and
the defeat of nikonur as mentioned much
of this material is unhistorical Roman
Catholic doctrines such as Purgatory
prays for the dead and the intercessory
work of glorified Saints find support in
second Maccabees
can you see why the Roman Catholic
Church wants them to be canonical of
course
because it supports their
Doctrine now the doctrine of purgatory
is essential to them
because they don't have salvation in
Christ they deny the atonement remember
and therefore they have to purge their
own sins
and that's why they need a purgatory
but I don't need a Purgatory I have
Christ that's the thing
so these books you know what these books
make me think of
it's like that series The Chosen
you can watch it
but there's no biblical foundation for
that no and the writers of it
acknowledges it and they're using make
believe they're making the stories up
you know if it's not biblical
and it takes you on the tangent and puts
you into another frame of mind
it is
I'm not interested there's no time for
this anymore study the Bible in the
spirit of Prophecy and get the Three
Angels message out to people and throw
this nonsense out yeah
not in the danger is once you start
using extraneous sources
it opens the way
for spurious doctrines like Purgatory
for example which is a key
a key doctrine of the Roman Catholic
Church it lays the basis for an entire
false Pagan religion
that is based on your own salvation
through your own works
right yes once you start opening the
door to that then you might as well
start opening the door to let the spirit
lead
that's the truth that's exactly and once
you start that Doctrine let the spirit
lead
then you can redefine love
then love means anything so if you love
trees you can marry a tree
let's not go into all the other
perversions that come along the line no
and then in the in the end as long as
you have redefined it as love
then Anything Goes
but let's leave Doctrine aside
opening the door
to false Doctrine
leads to a Floodgate Of world oh for
sure
do you know what's interesting is that
this is Roman Catholic driven
that means is Antichrist driven yes so
if you dangle in this
and you study this and you become an
expert in this you might just end up
like Henry Newman did and become a
cardinal in the Antichrist it might as
well become a cardinal now
we must never forget that Rome is a
brilliant system
because it can accommodate two classes
oh yeah and the two classes that it
accommodates is those that want to be
saved by their works
and those that want to be saved in their
sins
and they are Masters that incorporating
them both so when you look at the Roman
Catholic system and you look at the
Roman Catholic Cardinals
taking part in gay parades propagating
abortion and the other Lots shouting
against it it looks like total confusion
yeah but it and you have the ultra
conservatives those who want to be saved
by their works and those that want to be
saved in their sins both classes are
welcome no wonder the door is so Broad
and so wide it is and we've shown me
numerous times that even other religions
are accepted in in the Roman god system
now how far is this going to go let's
see how it's spreading over into the
Protestant churches well Martin read
this for us and tell us what's going on
now so there was interesting article
about a Lutheran Church a community
Lutheran Church that at a support for
the this pride month that was happening
all this woke
um and that's called it a sparkle Creed
yes that was read in the church
so we don't have to read the article we
can actually watch the video
okay well this was an interesting
article and actually a video that went
viral about uh Lutheran Church that had
a late the preacher the lady
read the sparkle Creed but now we have
to find out what the sparkle Creed is
let's read there in the second paragraph
the sparkle Creed is a version of the
Apostles Creed modified to include the
lgbtq plus community
the incident took place on Sunday June
25 with co-pastor Anna Helgen leading
the congregation she recites that God is
non-binary that Jesus Christ had two
dads and that love is love
calling for inclusion and diversity she
adds I believe in the Church of everyday
Saints as numerous creative and
resilient as patches on the age quilt
whose feet are grounded in mud and whose
eyes gaze at the stars in Wonder
Mountain our church has consistently
from its Inception resist the decreed
yes
because once you have a Creed
then you have actually created a set of
rules and understandings of what you
believe in the Bible
and you now exclude the Holy Spirit from
further
uh
advising you as to what the word is
actually saying
so we have no clue but the Bible
so the Bible is our Creed
and once you start going down this road
eventually Anything Goes
and you can bring Idols in you can do
whatever you like
because it's defined in within your
framework and you can call it Sparkle
Creed you know what and it's also
dangerous because even if you start
going to the official position of the
church
that can always also start creeping to
towards yeah the secular way of thinking
yes and Bible set aside especially when
it comes to issues of Health
or whatever whatever the government says
can become the short pattern of the
Church not church policy and become
church policy and church policy might
not be biblical policy exactly so we
have no Creed but the Bible
so let's have a look at this video of
what she said
I invite you to rise in body or spirit
and let us confess our faith today in
the words of the sparkle Creed
I believe in the non-binary god whose
pronouns are plural I believe in Jesus
Christ their child who wore a fabulous
tunic and had two dads and saw everyone
as a sibling child of God
I believe in the rainbow Spirit who
shatters our image of one white light
and refracts it into a rainbow of
gorgeous diversity
I believe in the Church of everyday
Saints as numerous creative and
resilient as patches on the ace quilt
whose feet are grounded in mud and whose
eyes gaze at the stars in wonder
I believe in the calling to each of us
that love is Love Is Love so beloved let
us love
I believe glorious God help my unbelief
amen
Martin do you have to now redefine Jesus
they definitely did so they redefine him
okay
who should Define Jesus for you the
Bible
the Bible God
yourself
and listen to a preacher the other day
and I I was quite
pleased with him and quite amused at him
he says if you want to know what God
says
then read your Bible
and if you want to hear What God Says
then read it loud
true very good yes
and that's the way it should be and
nothing else no that's true so this it
just shows you it goes from like you
always said it's going from the
ridiculous to the total Sublime
well if Society has gone totally mad
then it's good news because it tells us
where we are in the Stream of time
that's true let's watch this one how far
is the world going
let's talk about Miss Netherlands so the
weekend Ricky Valerie uh Coley who was a
transgender entrant to miss Netherlands
competition uh won the title so a
biological male has been voted Miss
Netherlands and will now take part in
Miss Universe Michaela your thoughts I
hope he wins Miss Universe I'm I'm
kidding I'm kidding it it's I don't even
know how to react to these situations
because women fought so hard to get
where we are today I was just looking at
uh the picture of the Boston marathon
runner in 1967 and it's this woman and
she's being grabbed by men on the track
because women weren't allowed to compete
that's where it started and now we're
here and there are men competing in our
Sports and I have no idea how feminism
came full it is it is it's so bizarre
and Cat I mean Only Yesterday Megan
rapino one of the great female sports
stars in American history came out on as
she retired this might be convenient
timing because it won't apply to her and
said I'd be very happy if trans athlete
Sports women come and play in the
American women's team well fine but what
happens if they're all 11 biological
males representing the American women's
team I mean this can't be right surely
so he's got a very good he's got a very
good point actually in that last last
statement what if all of the the girls
on the team is biological miles so well
let's change the football teams and make
all the males biological females
so wouldn't that be interesting
what is the devil Martin oh the master
of reversal
so what does he hate
yeah it's everything that God's put in
place and he hates two institutions in
particular
two that were blessed in Eden
marriage and the Sabbath and the Sabbath
and those are the two that is going to
attack come hell or high water that's it
and he's doing a pretty good job oh yes
but the laughing stock
is actually humanity is going along with
it yeah just shows you how gullible they
can be that's it so Martin when it comes
to the Sabbath
that's the next point of attack and the
last one because it attacks the
authority of God right that's it and
Bonnie Prince oh no sorry bunny King
Charles
[Music]
he is the climate activist
and he believes everything that Al Gore
believes yeah that nobody else in the
world that has any sense believes but
let's leave it at that they got a buddy
the climate tsar of the United States
John Kerry as well yes and and a bus
star which is the pope himself that's it
now let's see what they're going to do
about this climate issue because it has
to be driven to a point now yeah
everywhere we will we see this as
becoming climate Madness and we're just
reading about heat waves and I read now
the other day that the tar
on the roads is melting from the
terrible Heat
now imagine when I was a kid
in Cape Town on a hot day the tar melted
on the road we used to play with it yeah
so you know what they're making such
hype of things that have been taking
place on this Earth
for
ever that's it so let's see what this is
all about
two one King Charles helped turn on a
climate clock at a summit in London this
afternoon it triggers 150 similar clocks
across the major cities of the UK
counting down the seconds to 2030. the
estimated deadline for limiting climate
change to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels
notice they use a dial clock mechanism
like a compass almost like a flat earth
mazaroth type of clock there
keep that in mind when you watch this
which opens today
Hitler made mistakes and with this I
will correct them all
Hitler made mistakes and with this dial
of Destiny I will correct them all
interesting statement considering what
we're witnessing now in the world I
wonder what mistakes Hitler made he's
referring to in this whole trailer
starts off with a very familiar tune
called Sympathy for the Devil
laughs
I'm retiring
so they start this doomsday dial climate
clock the very same day that the dial of
Destiny opens and of course the trailer
is dubbed over with Sympathy for the
Devil
well Martin we've been saying it's a
luciferian agenda for a long time
and the drivers and the movers and the
Shakers of the luciferian agenda are the
Jesuits yes
whether they like it or not finished
they're the Jesuits because they hate
the Bible that poisonous asp
and they're the ones in Jesuit theater
the running the old show and
historically the crown has been ceded to
Rome that's it so it sits on Bonnie King
Charles's head
by the grace of Rome that's it and he
serves the Dragon
and the dragon is the symbol of Rome
so you know we have all of these
interesting things and then you have
their their Skull and Bones Masters all
of these puppeteers and puppets
are all on the same bandwagon and
they're leading to Wards one thing
climate lockdowns
and climate rest days yeah namely
Sundays it will it's coming so let's
have a look at what what uh Fox News has
to say about John Kerry it's interesting
they call him the climate Tsar
but whose tune is he playing the Vatican
the buying the Americans tune so he's
playing the vatican's drum so he's
actually the Vatican drummer he is very
good because remember that video we've
shown it a few times already where he
says that the pope is the moral leader
of the of the entire world yes so let
these bonesmen
throw their bones have a look
John Kerry has a new climate Target
farmers Ashley I know all about this
story but why don't you explain it to
our viewers
I'll try our fearless climates are who
Jets around the world by the way in his
private aircraft taking AIM now at
Farmers because they're polluting the
environment he says Mr Kerry claims
agriculture production creates 33
percent of the world's total greenhouse
gas emissions and the fight against
climate change cannot be tackled without
addressing what the farmers are doing in
fact Kerry is refusing to call it
climate change anymore he says it's
climate crisis and Kerry says emissions
from the food system alone are projected
to cause another half a degree of
warming by the year 2050 the former
secretary of state says lives depend on
world leaders and scientists developing
the tools necessary to lower agriculture
emissions it's all about the cows
foreign
agriculture has to go
they're fighting against the Bible
because the Bible says see time and
harvest will not pass
interesting that the spirit of Prophecy
also tells us to
secure for ourselves a piece of land
where we can grow our own produce and
all of this what's the situation of
South Africa and farmers
they want to get you off yes so the
devil is making it increasingly
difficult to do what the Bible and
spirit of Prophecy is telling us to do
correct so this is part of the agenda of
buying and selling of total control
that's actually what he says it's all
about control
and they're also going after the
appliances and I see that Biden has just
uh said that he wants to up the game
there
so your gas stove and all of these
things will have to go because they're
contributing to the tar melting on a hot
summer's day as it has been melting for
the last hundreds of years
but let's leave it at that but Martin
let's look at this ludicrous stuff that
they are doing
but always remember that you're looking
at it from a Biblical perspective so no
matter how ludicrous it looks no matter
how excited you get about it no matter
how angry you want to get about it it's
part of the prophecy of where we are
heading
so let's embrace it
not embrace it in the sense of supported
no but embrace it in terms of warning
Humanity as to where we are going that's
it yeah well you mentioned now that they
want to stop gas and all of this in
London it's also very serious at this
stage no fires wood fires no gas stoves
and 20 mile an hour
speed limits
it's going to be interesting and fun to
watch how they're going to implement
that in Africa by telling people not to
burn wood anymore
and destroying the lifeline of the whole
African continent it will be interesting
it will be interesting let's see what
happens you know we got them to wear
masks in the middle of nowhere which has
served absolutely no purpose or totally
ridiculous but nevertheless we'll see
how many people go along with this thing
yes but yeah well now we've got Nigel
farage that will tell us a little bit
more what what's happening in this we're
going to go for climate lockdowns and
climate lockdowns on the lead to Sunday
legislation that's it that's what
could climate lockdowns be on the
horizon according to Nigel farage the
answer is yes and then this Tuesday
mayor Khan says the air quality in
London today is going to be poor and
that's because Summer has finally
arrived on our little island all right
so he says please don't use your car
unless it's absolutely necessary do not
let your car idle do not burn wood and
so on and so forth now if I'd said to
you four years ago
that we'd be locked down because of a
flu-like virus that had come from China
you would not on this program but
believe me and I'm telling you here and
now that in the name of climate change
in the neighbor pollution we will
certainly in London within the next few
years have a period when the mayor says
You must not use your car at all and air
quality is so bad you must stay at home
this isn't about pollution it isn't
about climate change it's about
controlling Our Lives we're becoming
like China and don't think it won't come
to you because it will it's the same
Panic peddling and the same hysteria
hustling that they used to frighten
people into silence and compliance
during covet fear equals control and
control equals power and nobody should
buy it the way fear was used during the
lockdown was extraordinary in the
millions of our elderly people shut
themselves in their homes shut
themselves off from their kids their
grandkids from their neighbors their
friends because government
advertisements were telling them if you
leave your front door you might die they
did it were covered and they'll do it
for climate and they'll do it with
pollution and the worrying thing about
this
is how few so-called conservative
politicians and commentators are
prepared to stand up to it that's the
thing that really worried me the most
you know it's fascinating you have
people that are born free that are so
willing to give up their freedoms
um to accept mandates that are crazy at
Drive 20 miles an hour maybe we want
they want to ride a little scooter bike
um more people have to stand up to this
and these right parties have to push
back on these crazy environmentalists
because those conservatives who won't
stand up are part of the elite that's
why because those were the rules don't
apply to them it's all you know it's a
big Club it is now you will have seen
various scare stories uh about oh
there's a new pandemic coming the next
one's going to be worse this sort of
stuff you will have read about that what
you won't have read much about is how
the World Health Organization I've
warned you about this many many times
before on this show uh are desperate to
have some kind of global pandemic treaty
whereby it would be the World Health
Organization who says to separate
countries is at the World Health
Organization will have the powers to be
able to say such and such a state or
such such a nation or country or
whatever is in a pandemic situation and
must be locked down even if that entity
says no we're not or disputes it that's
the fear of how bad it could be there's
dispute about whether that's what the
agenda will be there's so many things
that we need to be vigilant about and
what people need to be vigilant about
but they get called conspiracy theorists
and whack jobs and things like that the
fundamental idea behind all of this is
this idea that freedom is somehow the
problem and this is the issue with so
many of the issues that we face whether
it's the pandemic whether it's the
climate crisis if you want to say that
in quotes whatever the issue is people
having too much freedom is the thing
that annoys the regulators and we're
going to see this we saw the climate
Council this week come out and say that
well to you know fight the climate thing
not only do we need to all move to EVS
but we need to own half as many cars I
take half as many car trips we need to
take trips according to the public
transport schedule you know we see this
on level after level after level and
this is what people need to be really
Vigilant about it is not Freedom that is
the problem it is always the people who
want to take your freedom away and we're
now in a world where really it's not
left versus right it's authoritarianism
versus Freedom as James says or the
collective the greater good versus
freedom of the individual to make their
own choices and what we saw during
covert which is why we must have a royal
commission as Rita was saying to find
out what actually happened during covert
you must have that Royal commission into
what actually happened and what did
happen to our freedoms and at what costs
they came
it's therefore with great hope that I
declare covid-19 over as a global Health
Emergency
however
that does not mean covid-19 is over as a
global Health threat
last week covid-19 claimed live every
three minutes
and that's just the this we know about
as we speak thousands of people around
the world are fighting for their lives
in intensive care units
and millions more continue to live with
the debilitating effects of post-covid
19 condition
this virus is here to stay
Martin let's just make something quite
plain again
they're all looking for the enemy
the enemy is some vague power out there
that wants to take away your your
freedom
the only organization that really wants
to take away your freedom and regain its
original Power is the Beast of
Revelation that's it so if people would
do a little bit of research
and look at all the movers and shakers
in in governments in whatever sphere
because they're all involved whether
it's sport we'll talk about whether it's
sport we must talk about sport
whether it's sport
whether it's the health
World whether it's the banking cartels
whether it's big business whether it's
government whether it's United Nations
who are the movers and shakers have a
look what is their pedigree
you will find they either belong
to the Knights of Malta there are either
Knights of Malta
or they belong to Opus Dei
or they are Jesuits
and they get rewarded by the Jesuits we
take fouchi for example didn't it wasn't
he just made
superb wonderful professor at Georgetown
for a work wonderfully done when
everybody says what he did was totally
ridiculous but it gets rewarded right by
whom
all right now if you're a knight
then you are in a military order
and you take orders we've said this
before
would you take orders from you take
orders from your general
now where is the general of the Knights
of Malta and who do they swear
allegiance to they spare allegiance to
the Pope
but they take the orders from a general
yeah right we happen to be the black
book
okay
and if you look at the kings of the
world including Bonnie King Charles
doesn't he wear a Maltese cross yes
Sizzle is associated with the Order of
Malta and the Order of Malta is a
military order that is subject to the
Pope the same with the order of the bath
whatever what order they want to they
can wear their garters they can do
whatever they want to talk they can sit
in their little meetings and you know
whether they are the Builder burgers or
whether they are the whatever the bottom
line is
who started the boulder burgers
wasn't that Joseph rettinger Jesuit
so behind all of these things sits the
Roman Catholic hierarchy and if people
don't want to see it they are blind
like you mentioned before
how they ruled for a thousand two
hundred and sixty years they ruled this
Earth and they want to rule it again
that's it and what do they have to do in
order to do that they have to bludgeon
you into submission
and you have to accept their Mark and
you have to accept that Doctrine and you
have to wonder and think like them I
refuse to wonder and think like them and
I will not accept their Mark for sure
but they are determined to do that the
Bible says they will control banking
because you won't be able to buy or sell
they will be able to control whatever
you do
so the next point is can they
Spike into your banking accounts and do
whatever they want yeah so what look at
what some of these news anchors or some
people
you can see that they see there's
something wrong yet but they don't know
what it is and they don't know who like
you said they're looking at the pawn yes
the bottom guy who's they think is the
elite but this Elite is answering to the
system exactly this Nigel farage
the article that we've got here is about
him his bank
being closed his bank account I close
this bank account yes because we spoke
up on National Television Martin
so your bank account's secure no it
cannot be you never all right let's read
then to us what it says there yeah the
terrifying rise of debanking last week
former brexit party leader nairol faraj
announced that his Scout's bank account
of over 40 years has been closed against
his will and without any real
explanation the motive might have been
politically speculated perhaps couch the
prestigious private bank for the wealthy
had taken exception to his support for
brexit farage went on to claim that nine
other banks have refused his custom too
this seemed like a potential case of
what has become known as debanking that
is the practice of withholding Bank
services to individuals because of the
views they hold this hold is right there
is that what the Bible says what's going
to happen exactly
exactly what's going to happen can they
do it they're already doing it now whose
tune are the banks dancing to
they're going back to the Vatican the
dancing to the Vatican tune because the
Vatican controls them is it so the
Vatican is also pro-climate change
are against it you might be in trouble
so read on as it stands we do not know
exactly why farage's account was closed
but we do know that he is not the only
one claiming to have been debanked in
fact over the past week or so numerous
cases have emerged of people being
denied access to financial services
seemingly on the basis of their
political views this has included
activists parents groups and even people
with no political background at all
all right it's always our motive to show
that we're heading towards the
Fulfillment of Prophecy and I wish
people would would understand where we
are in the Stream of time it's serious
it's very serious
and it cannot go on for much longer in
fact I hope it does not go no on for
much longer because I can't stand the
idiocy anymore
it's true because people are so gullible
and just being swept into this flood of
Lies into the flood of Lies
and who was the father of Lies
Satan
and the Bible says truth has been thrown
to the ground it's true so Martin let's
hear what the mayor of New York has to
say this is a significant moment and
we're going to look back on what we're
doing here in New York and what we're
doing in London and how this impacts the
way we have been thinking and it also is
going to be in in an uncomfortable
moment for many uh it is easy to talk
about uh missions that are coming from
vehicles and how it impacts our carbon
footprint it is easy to talk about the
emissions that's coming from buildings
and how it impacts our environment but
we now have to talk about beef
and I don't know if people are really
ready for this conversation and we can't
have a level of hypocrisy where we want
to ensure that we do local laws to
address the emissions that's come from
uh fossil fuel but not willing to have a
real conversation on what food is doing
to us and today we are saying to New
Yorkers and really to the globe that it
impacts our planet I always say we have
two mothers one give birth to us the
other sustains us and we have been
destroying the one that sustains US
based on the food that we have been
consuming we are leading the world and
ensuring we combat climate change and if
we're going to accomplish this goal it
must be accomplished by being honest you
cannot leave the third leading cause of
climate change
unacknowledged and when you do a
comparison
the numbers that food contributes
compared to Transportation they are
extremely close it's almost a dead
evening so we can't talk about cars we
can't talk about buildings if we're not
talking about the food that also
contribute to this crisis today we are
saying to New Yorkers who are serious
about this charge of cleaning up our
environment we now have a new Focus that
is also must include food
is that in line with Biblical prophecy
yes
so everything is there if everything is
falling into well it has been falling
into place for quite a few years already
by the way I don't have two mothers I
had one
one mother
isn't it crazy you've got those other
people that says Jesus had two dads now
you've got a new mother as well the only
one who has two dads is me I have a
Earthly father and I have a Heavenly
Father
but as for two mothers forget it
now some of these things are discussed
in meetings where not everybody attends
and nobody even hears about it but the
movers and the Shakers make decisions
now this Congress lady attended one of
these meetings and she's going to give a
report
and she's quite alarmed that what was
stated there but nothing was ever said
in the media true I mean we we heard
earlier about on that news
um Sky News Australia that he mentioned
this World Health Organization treaty
we've mentioned it before but let's hear
what it actually entails congresswoman
Bachmann tell us a little bit about what
you experienced when you went to Geneva
Switzerland and we're a part of at least
the uh audience listening to all the
things going on at the World Health
Organization I and this is
because the plan envisioned is that
every person on Earth would come under
the Dominion and control of the World
Health Organization it was just Monday
of this week one week after the World
Health assembly concluded that there was
a an action absolute bombshell press a
press letter that went out that said the
European Union has already developed a
global digital passport that would
regulate the ability of people to take
transportation and it would also
regulate our health issues that Global
digital passport which essentially would
be a QR code on your mobile phone an
individual would have to be in
compliance with the mandates of the
World Health Organization in order to be
able to travel
in order to be able to move about so
this was announced on Monday they didn't
wait to pass amendments or pass a global
treaty they announced that the World
Health Organization is adopting what
Europe came up with that already covers
80 countries out of the 194. the
question is when will the United States
go into this system because this is how
you enforce Global government through
this Global digital passport it is a
reality and Monday it was announced that
the who will take over the European
digital passport and they also stated
this will be the first building block
presumably merging digital currency
digital health records our entire life
will eventually be merged onto this
digital QR code and they said the
effective date is June of 2023. in other
words right now This Global digital
passport is effective now it won't be a
year from now our lives will be
completely upended absent a miracle or
an intervening hand from the Lord we're
looking at at less than a year at this
point of having this full digital
passport enforced and actually
um out in play for everyone in the world
so they it's envisioned it's created
it's a matter of getting everyone on
board and when you look at the 307
proposed amendments to the international
Health rules and the global pandemic
treaty both of them mandate compliance
by member states they talk about how
they member they mandate compliance but
they also talk about how they have
committees to stop anybody from talking
about this and it's really shocking when
you think the mainstream media hasn't
talked about this that cable media has
and the social media hasn't been talking
about this and yet through all
alternative media sources like
yourselves really more than half of the
people don't trust the system they know
something about this just through
alternative media that's why the the
global amendments and the pandemic
treaty Envision shutting down even
alternative media everyone has to be in
compliance with the message given out by
global government and that will be
within the year that they'll start on
these restrictions on speech and so
that's why use use our speech as long as
we can
Martin
use our speech as long as we can
and the time frame
we have lots of time right
it's already it's already in all right
so if we don't have time
then shouldn't we make
double efforts triple efforts to get the
message out definitely we I don't think
there's much time left for public
evangelism nope no no no also not
media well I doubt if anything is going
to last long
to get the message out like on these
platforms all right
in the Middle Ages um
did the Roman Catholic Church tolerate
descent no not one bit who came and
fetched you the Inquisition mm-hmm
all right so there was no dissent
did they control every aspect every
single aspect of life was controlled all
right so they're control freaks par
excellence
Martin
this system
is a counterfeit system
it is a system that counterfeits the
true government of God the difference is
that God's government is based on Agape
Agape is Selfless Love
this is based on their leader who was a
liar from the beginning and a murderer
and his
selfishness personified
so the two systems have control
the two systems require obedience God
requires obedience and he says if you do
not keep my law you will die
God requires absolute obedience but the
basis for the requirement of the
obedience is Love Is Love
the other one also requires absolute
obedience
has God's system got a right arm yes it
has a health message yes does the other
system have a health message yes
uh
is God ever going to force you no is the
other system going to force you yes
hmm
is God's systems right yes
because God knows what he does right and
he he implemented it and he designed us
and he's doing it for our best yes all
right so
the Beast
wants absolute control the Beast wants
worship yes
now if we cannot
change your heart to worship you
you must change your behavior through to
worship him yeah and if he gets you to
obey him even though your heart's not
right it doesn't matter because whom you
obey you are actually serving that means
you're worshiping him that's it you've
chosen an idol so that part of God knows
my heart it cannot it cannot it doesn't
have any ground it doesn't wash when you
don't your fruits don't tell it you you
have to have you have to have the fruits
so Martin
the world is in a final stage of
conflict between two ideologies and the
the system is beginning to get a vice
grip on everybody have there been warned
yes does God make sure that the people
hear the warning yes and what about this
Dr Martin
did he plainly State what is going on he
warned them 10 years ago already even in
in parliaments and the public places
it's just here
it is a particularly interesting
location for me to be sitting today
given that
over a decade ago I sat in this very
chair right here in the European Union
Parliament
and at that time I warned the world of
what was coming
I urge this body
and I urged people around the world
that the weaponization of nature Against
Humanity had dire consequences
tragically I sit here today
with that unfortunate line that I don't
like to say which I told you so
and in 1990 they found out that there
was a problem with vaccines
they didn't work
yes from 1990 until 2018
every single publication concluded that
coronavirus escapes the vaccine impulse
because it modifies and mutates too
quickly for vaccines to be effective and
since 1990 to 2018 that is the published
science ladies and gentlemen that's
following the science
and not paid for by pharmaceutical
companies these are Publications that
are independent scientific research that
shows unequivocally including efforts of
the Chimera modifications made by Ralph
Barrick in the University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill all of them show
vaccines do not work on Coronavirus
because in 2002 the University of North
Carolina Chapel Hill patented and I
quote an infectious replication
defective clone of Coronavirus
infectious replication defective means a
weapon
it means something meant to Target an
individual but not have collateral
damage to other individuals that's what
infectious replication defective means
and that patent was filed in 2002 on
work funded by niaid's Anthony fauci
from 1999 to 2002 and that work patented
at the University of North Carolina
Chapel Hill mysteriously preceded SARS
1.0
by a year
Dave are you suggesting that SARS 1.0
wasn't from a wet Market in Wuhan
are you suggesting it might have come
from a laboratory
in the University of North Carolina
Chapel Hill no I'm not suggesting it I'm
telling you that's the facts
we engineered SARS
SARS is not a naturally occurring
phenomenon the naturally occurring
phenomenon is called the common cold
it's called influenza-like illness it's
called gastroenteritis that's the
naturally occurring Coronavirus
SARS
is the research developed by humans
weaponizing a life system model to
actually attack human beings and they
patented it in 2002.
now Martin whether this Dr Martin is
legit or not is not for us to judge he
has some very interesting points they're
based on facts
the fact that he is so
readily speaking at these high levels
tells me there might be a reason why
it's permitted to do this yeah
also where's some interesting rings
but nevertheless
the information is there now what is the
information actually do
the inflammation sows fear
that someone out there is out to destroy
Humanity
and we need to protect ourselves against
that someone out there
but there's someone out there is never
the one that really is the problem no so
they don't mind front enemies
bottom line
did he speak for or against fauci much
against much against right
I'm just saying hegelian dialectic
that's it how you put two toe stories in
and were they going to believe the one
narrative or the other narrative
uh depends on your circumstances very
often
now Martin it's interesting to me that
Dr Martin
is allowed to speak at all of these
illustrious forums yeah
and
whether I buy his narrative or don't buy
his narrative is actually irrelevant
the fact is it brings some important
points but he also sows a measure of
Suspicion and fear
that someone out there is wanting to
kill you yeah yeah
and that someone is undefined
but there is an enemy out there who
wants to kill you
is he for or against Dr fauci totally
against totally against
but on the other hand Dr fauci is
elevated to high levels
by the Jesuit Society yes now if we
understand that they are Masters at the
hegelian dialectic
putting opposite views Into The Fray
so that they can manipulate minds and at
the same time keep mind so confused that
they cannot see the real picture yes or
suck them into big standing on a soapbox
like we've always said so our view has
always been
just pull back
get the picture
and ask yourself
whether it's from the left whether it's
from the right whether it's extreme
whether it's not extreme
fit into the biblical picture
so here you have Georgetown names Dr
Anthony fauci distinguished professor
and in his role deemed the University's
highest professional honor
fauci will participate in medical and
graduate education and engage with
students according to the university we
are deeply honored to welcome Dr Anthony
fauci a dedicated public servant
humanitarian Visionary Global Health
leader to Georgetown University you know
these Jesuits
I almost said they make me sick
um I won't say it
you know what just read this let's just
read this other part as well Dr fauci
has embodied the Jesuit value of being
in service to others throughout his
career and we are grateful to have his
expertise strong leadership and
commitment to guide the next generation
of leaders you know it almost seems as
if the man is a Jesuit with a short Rock
okay just explain to us a bit what does
that mean well that's one that is
Incognito that is in society marries
it's a real actually a real Jesus
now I'm not saying it is so because I do
not know so because these things are
obviously so secret that how could I
possibly know even though he has
acknowledged
very plainly how supportive of Jesuit
theology is correct
so if you're so supportive and
Georgetown honors him in such a fashion
but Dr Martin denigrates him and speaks
at another public forum then you know
what I'm weary of all of them okay now
you must also take into consideration
um
Robert F Kennedy was on Fox News prime
time saying that yes he would actually
if it comes to that jail Anthony fauci
and then Rand Paul also went on because
he uh that same Jesse Watters from Fox
News uncovered that fauci is still
protected
like ex-president would be protected by
secret service and stuff I've watched
many of these discussions
where Rand Paul you know really attacks
these people and the answers are so
slippery
and no matter what the accusation is
nothing ever comes from no that's so as
far as I'm concerned it's part of the
Galleon dialectic that's exactly what I
wanted to come to so you've got the
Democrat
um candidate for president you got the
right the conservative everybody yeah
is on this thing but it's part of the
Gillian Islands part of the egalian
dialect the question again bottom line
is where is it leading
and
the ultimate thing that we're trying to
show is who's behind it
who's behind it because these people the
Jesuits
and the Knights of Malta they're always
there in The Fray
in the highest echelons of leadership
and nobody looks at you they're subject
to no
the Beast of Revelation
is who they are subject to
that Beast is a control freak
that Beast has a mock and it is
determined to make its Mark count
because that Mark is contrary to God's
mark it attacks the authority of God
and we have to make a choice between
accepting the authority of God for which
he has set the symbol the Sabbath or the
authority of the church for which it has
said a symbol a mock Sunday that's our
choice that's right
Heavenly Father
the world is sitting on the edge
and no one seems to know
we're heading towards a precipice
time is running out
we have a message to bear
help us by all means
the total user and listener involvement
to reach the goal that you have set
for your end time truth to reach the
world is my prayer in Jesus name amen
amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign